- So I have a question.
If you owe a billion dollars,
are you a billionaire?
Now, sure, Alex Jones
has been ordered to pay
close to a billion dollars,
but this is great news for Alex Jones.
He's finally going to
get that real bankruptcy
that he's been angling for
for all this time.
- [Judge] Total of $120 million.
- Yeah!
- Initialed by juror-
- And that's because a Connecticut jury
has found that Jones and
Infowars should pay $965 million
to people who've suffered
from his false claim
that the Sandy Hook Elementary
school shooting was a hoax.
Robbie Parker, the father of a
six year old girl named Emily
who was murdered that day, said, quote,
- All I can really say is
that I'm just proud that
what we were able to accomplish was just
to simply tell the truth,
and it shouldn't be this hard,
and it shouldn't be this scary.
- While Parker gave his
heartbreaking statements,
Jones was live on Infowars,
calling the verdict hilarious.
Telling his audience
that he'd never pay these
people a single penny,
and asked his fan base for donations,
because,
of course.
So the real question is,
will this Info-hole finally
have to pay up, or what?
Now, here's the background on this case.
The Connecticut verdict
is right on the heels
of a Texas jury verdict
awarding millions of
dollars to the parents
of other children killed in the massacre.
In both cases, Jones did not
defend the case on the merits,
and the courts entered
default judgments against him
because of all kinds of
shenanigans on Jones' part.
He effectively refused to comply
with discovery in all of these cases.
The lawsuit stems from Infowars' broadcast
about the shooting at Sandy
Hook Elementary School in 2012
that killed 20 first grade children,
six educators, and wounded two others.
The plaintiffs included the
relatives of five children,
and three educators killed
in the mass shooting,
plus an FBI agent
who was one of the first
responders to the scene.
As the plaintiffs in
this case pointed out,
quote, "Overwhelming and
indisputable evidence
shows exactly what happened
at Sandy Hook Elementary
School on December 14th, 2012.
26 children and educators were shot
by a lone youth, armed with an AR-15.
Now, despite all of the evidence
that 26 people lost their lives that day,
Jones' broadcast lies about Sandy Hook
for over five years on
his Infowars news program.
Jones and Infowars contributors said
that the entire thing was a hoax
staged by the government,
in order to take away the audience's guns.
Jones and his contributors
said things like,
"The massacre might really be a hologram,"
or an "illusion,"
that it was "the fakest
thing since the $3 bill,"
and that other Sandy
Hook families were paid
to actually fake their loved one's deaths.
Now, the lead plaintiff
in the Connecticut case
was Erica Lafferty,
the daughter of school principal
Dawn Lafferty Hochsprung,
who was murdered by the same gunman
as the Sandy Hook children.
Now, the plaintiffs pleaded
four causes of action
against Jones:
invasion of privacy,
negligent and intentional infliction
of emotional distress,
violations of Connecticut
Unfair Practices Act,
CUTPA, C-U-T-P-A,
and defamation.
Now, the case eventually went to trial,
but only on damages.
Jones had already lost
the liability phase,
because of repeated refusals
to respond to the court's orders,
and to participate in
the discovery process.
Now, Jones constantly whines
about the legal system,
and a supposed grand conspiracy
to deny him the right to due process,
because these whines bring him viewers
and help him sell supplements
that are basically just trucker speed.
However, in reality, Jones
wasn't denied due process.
He simply refused to fully defend the case
and engage in the discovery process,
or listen to the court's orders.
And as we've discussed
many times on this channel,
a SLAPP lawsuit is filed by someone
in order to silence and intimidate
people for their speech.
And SLAPP suits are genuinely bad,
since they can allow powerful
people to stifle free speech
simply by draining the
target's financial resources.
And when the Sandy Hook
survivors sued Jones,
he filed motions to dismiss
the plaintiffs' complaints,
pursuant to Connecticut's
anti-SLAPP statute.
In order to respond to the motions,
the plaintiffs moved
for limited discovery,
and Jones opposed it.
Jones and the plaintiffs
went back and forth
for more than a year,
with Jones usually asking for more time,
and the court giving him that time.
Eventually, Jones stopped complying
with the discovery orders entirely,
even though the court had
agreed to some of his requests
about limiting the
scope of that discovery.
But finally, in 2021,
the trial court said
that Jones simply refused
to comply with the discovery orders.
So Judge Bellis criticized Jones' attorney
for providing only sanitized,
inaccurate financial records,
and showed a callous disregard
for her repeated rulings
to provide complete analytics data.
She found Jones' attorney's
actions were, quote,
"not just careful,
but constituted a pattern
of obstructive conduct."
Quote, "Neither the court nor the parties
can expect perfection
when it comes to the discovery process.
What is required, however,
and what all parties are entitled to,
is fundamental fairness
that the other side produces information
which is within their knowledge,
possession, and power,
and that the other side
meets its continuing duty
to disclose additional and new material."
And so, when Jones refused,
the judge entered default
judgment against Jones.
A default judgment is a binding judgment
in favor of the other party,
based on some failure to take action
by the other party.
In other words,
the court ruled in favor of
the plaintiffs by default.
But after liability was
established by default,
the Connecticut case went to trial
on how much damages Jones had to pay.
Each of the plaintiffs presented evidence
about what they experienced
as they listened to Jones lie
about the Sandy Hook shooting,
how it impacted their
health, jobs, and lives.
William Sherlock's wife, Mary,
was a school psychologist
killed at Sandy Hook.
He testified that he was harassed online
by people claiming that
his wife never existed.
People made up conspiracy
theories about Sherlock,
saying he was involved
with the shooter's father,
or that he was part of a
shadowing network of financiers
with a motive to create a hoax.
Robert Parker testified
that less than one day
after his daughter's murder,
Jones went on his show and
called Parker an actor.
Later that same night,
hateful comments were posted
to the Facebook memorial page for Emily.
Parker said he removed
Emily's Facebook memorial page
weeks after the shooting,
because of the harassment
was just too much to control.
Vicki Soto was a teacher
killed in the attack.
Her son said that after President
Obama praised his mother,
people commented on a Facebook post
claiming that he wasn't real,
the family wasn't real,
and that his mother didn't exist.
Plaintiffs in this case argued,
and the court recognized,
that Jones intended to
activate his audience.
Not satisfied with just
misinforming the audience,
Jones urged his viewers
to investigate the situation on their own.
Millions of people watch
and listen to Infowars,
for some reason,
and some of them harassed, stalked,
and targeted the Sandy Hook families
and first responders.
The plaintiffs recounted
strangers showing up at their homes,
recording them,
shouting about conspiracy theories.
Mark Braden said that Jones fans
urinated on his
seven-year-old son's grave,
even threatening to dig up the coffin.
Hochsprung Lafferty testified
that people sent rape
threats to her house.
During the litigation,
Jones also turned his ire on the judge
and the lawyers involved in the case,
asking his fans to do his dirty work.
He said, quote, "To the
Patriots that are left,
and 4chan and 8chan,
and to anybody that's a patriot,
I'm under attack.
If they bring me down,
they'll bring you down.
I just have faith in you.
I'm under attack.
And I summon the mean war.
I summon all of it against the enemy."
The FBI concluded that fringe
political conspiracy theories
very likely motivated
some domestic extremists,
citing the Pizzagate conspiracy
and Jones' Sandy Hook lies.
The plaintiffs' legal team told the jury
that Jones knew the likely
impact of his actions,
but that he just didn't care.
In closing arguments,
plaintiffs' attorney
Chris Mattei said, quote,
"When every single one of these families
were drowning in grief,
Alex Jones put his foot
right on top of them."
But now we know the end result here.
We have a partial verdict.
The Alex Jones verdict was
only on compensatory damages.
The jury awarded plaintiffs
a whopping $965 million,
and the breakdown is as follows.
36 million to Bill Sherlock,
90 million to former FBI
agent William Aldenberg.
$55 million to David and Francine Wheeler,
57.6 million and 73.6 million
to Mark and Jacqueline Bardeney,
81.6 million and 73.6
million, respectively,
to Ian and Nicole Hockley,
$231 million to the
family of slain teacher
Victoria Leigh Soto,
$121 million to Robert Parker.
Now, on top of these compensatory damages,
the judge will determine
whether Jones owes punitive
damages next month.
Now, what's the difference
between punitive and compensatory damages?
Well, compensatory damages are designed
to compensate the victim's losses,
whereas punitive damages are
designed to punish bad actors.
Compensatory damages pay a
plaintiff back for losses.
They cover things like
medical bills, hospital bills,
future medical expenses,
and lost pay from missing work.
These damages are generally not capped,
which is why the verdict was so high.
Now, on the other hand,
states often have caps
on punitive damages.
What can I say?
Businesses often lobby to
prevent huge punitive awards,
because they don't like
paying huge punitive awards.
And this is often what's contemplated
by the term tort reform.
And under Connecticut common law,
courts have the discretion
to award punitive damages
when the evidence shows
a reckless indifference
to the rights of others,
or an intentional or wanton
violation of those rights.
This determination is made by the judge.
Common law punitive damages in Connecticut
are limited to the cost of
bringing the litigation,
including plaintiffs' attorney's fees.
However, the Connecticut Unfair
Trade Practices Act claim
opens Jones up to a bigger
punitive damages award.
The punitive damages
awarded under the Connecticut
Unfair Trade Practices Act
are not capped.
In order to support an
award of punitive damages
under that act,
quote, "The evidence must
reveal a reckless indifference
to the rights of others
or intentional and wanton
violation of those rights."
A plaintiff doesn't even need to plead
or prove compensatory damages
in order to recover punitive
damages under the act,
but since the application of
punitive damages under that act
is so broad,
the Connecticut Supreme Court has noted
that it creates an essentially
equitable cause of action.
In other words,
it's very good for the plaintiffs.
In Connecticut,
if jurors find that punitive
damages are appropriate,
the judge then determines that amount.
This will happen at a
separate hearing in November.
Jones characterized his stance
as a boycott of the trial.
Since his lack of compliance
with court rules and procedures
has resulted in two default
judgments and two big verdicts,
you might think that he
would change strategies
for punitive damages,
but he is, of course, more likely
to double down on his losing strategy.
(Alex yells)
Now, so far,
all the money awarded to the
plaintiffs in the Jones case
is for compensatory damages.
And although Jones will certainly appeal,
judges are often reluctant
to reduce a jury award,
especially in a state like Connecticut,
which has no caps on compensatory damages.
So it's possible that the awards
will be reduced on appeal,
but they won't be automatically reduced,
as punitive damages often are.
Now, I should also note that, often,
juries are not told about
limits on punitive damages,
so they don't shift what would
normally be a punitive damage
into a compensatory damage award.
And some have speculated here
that following along the limits in Texas
on punitive damages,
it's possible that this jury
overloaded the compensatory damages
in this particular case.
But at the moment,
there's no way to know.
Juries are a black box.
Now, Jones also complicated his appeal
by refusing to put on a
defense in the damages phase.
He could have called his own witnesses
and testified himself,
like he did in Texas.
By doing so, there would've
been evidence on the record
showing why the damages
should have been lower,
and the jury could have considered
whether Jones was contrite,
whether he made a formal apology,
whether he did the things to ensure
that the Infowars contributors
won't make crazy claims
like this in the future.
But since he did not
put on his own evidence,
the appeal is gonna be
less straightforward.
Now, as for mitigating factors,
Jones has not helped his case
by going on his show
and stating that the lawsuits
are trying to stop him
from talking about Parkland and Uvalde.
Alex Jones is suggesting
that maybe there's a conspiracy going on
in those two horrific mass shootings.
Now, this kind of rhetoric
is probably not gonna help
him show that he's sorry,
that he's learned his lesson,
or any of the things he
half-heartedly argued
in the Texas case.
The bigger question that
everyone wants to know
is will the plaintiffs ever get paid?
Jones says he only has about
$2 million to his name,
yet Jones raised millions of dollars
after the Texas verdict came out.
Experts testified that Infowars
is between 100 and $250 million,
and plaintiffs' lawyers
promised to chase Jones
to the end of the year,
to collect on the judgment.
So how will they do that?
Well, lawyers will have to connect Jones
to the many shell
companies that he's set up
for Infowars and his
associated businesses.
They'll probably argue
that even though these entities
are corporations and LLCs,
that the companies and Jones
are legally the same entity,
and the corporate veil should be pierced.
If that eventually happens,
Jones' personal assets could be seized
as well as the corporate assets.
Now, all of this implicates
the bankruptcy court, too.
As we've discussed before,
Jones and his companies
have filed for bankruptcy protection,
but Jones has suffered some setbacks.
A bankruptcy judge removed the lawyer
and chief restructuring officer
for Free Speech Systems,
the parent company of Infowars,
after they failed to disclose
prior connections to Jones.
The judge also directed
the bankruptcy trustee
to examine Free Speech
Systems' financial affairs,
operations, and insider relationships.
This happened after creditors
complained to the court
that the company was hiding its assets
through complex corporate structures.
As I discussed in my last Jones video,
a company owned by Jones's
parents, PQPR Holdings,
says it's a major creditor
of Free Speech Systems.
Jones allegedly owes
Mom and Pop $54 million.
But the bankruptcy judge found
that there has been,
quote, "a lack of candor"
by the companies and their lawyers,
and this means that the bankruptcy case
is already traveling the same path
as the Texas and Connecticut lawsuits.
Now, Liz Dye is a fantastic journalist
who has been following
the Jones bankruptcy,
where most of the action
is likely to take place
in the future.
Yes, she is a complete masochist.
So let's ask her.
Liz, what effect is this
verdict likely to have
on the rest of the bankruptcies?
- Yesterday, Jones promised his viewers
that they could shower him with cash,
and not have to worry
that any of the money
would go to the Sandy Hook victims.
The reality is that his
company, FSS, is in bankruptcy
and he doesn't really have
control over it anymore.
And because Alex Jones is Alex Jones,
he's done a bunch of really shady things
that mean he has even less control
than a normal debtor would in bankruptcy.
The most egregious thing he did
was to have the company
sign two promissory notes
for upwards of $50 million
right around the time
that he got defaulted
in the Sandy Hook cases.
So, suddenly, the company
which supplies his beet juice
and male vitality pills remembered
that it hadn't billed FSS for
years for products supplied,
and so FSS owed the drug
supplier $50 million,
at least in theory.
So, in 2021, FSS signed these two notes,
and started shoveling
mountains of cash out the door
to the drug supply company.
The effect of the notes
is to make the drug supply company
first in line to get paid.
But it turns out that
the supplement company
is owned, in whole, by
Jones and his parents
through a series of Nevada LLCs.
So what he's done is
effectively impoverished FSS,
and claimed all of its assets
for himself personally,
which is pretty convenient.
Months ago, the Texas plaintiff sued,
saying that the notes
were fraudulent transfers
and also alleging that Jones
had made a lot of cash
transfers to himself
from the company coffers.
So the bankruptcy court
is looking both at the promissory notes
and at those cash transfers,
to see if they should be clawed back.
So how much the plaintiffs get paid, here,
really depends on whether the
court tosses out the notes
and claws back that
cash from Jones himself.
Secondarily, Jones claims the right
to have FSS indemnify
him for any jury verdict,
which would mean that he's
not on the hook, personally,
for any of the money
owed to these plaintiffs.
And that would be cool for him,
because he could loot the company,
claim all of its assets were
owed to him, personally,
and then, free from
any personal liability,
he can go and do the same
thing somewhere else.
So he can start Shminfowars,
and sell male vitality pills there,
using the same shtick that he uses here.
So there are a lot of moving
parts in this bankruptcy,
and I think that's
where most of the action
is gonna wind up.
- Yes, at this point,
Shminfowars sounds more reputable
than the original Infowars.
Definitely give Liz a follow on Twitter.
Now, Alex Jones isn't
personally in bankruptcy yet.
It's going to be a fight,
but his personal assets
are likely to be subject
to this giant award.
And I should probably make
a video on this topic.
But the way lawyers go
after people's assets
when they're subject to court judgements,
is a fascinating process in and of itself.
You go through a whole
writ of attachment process,
to go after an individual's
salary, bank accounts,
and assets, to satisfy the judgment.
And there's a whole bunch of law on this
because the only thing lawyers
love more than winning a case
is getting paid.
Of course, Jones has
tried to hide his assets
through his corporate entities,
but the bankruptcy court
was already paying very close
attention to these companies
because they are in bankruptcy.
Infowars' parent company,
Free Speech Systems,
is being monitored
by the Department of
Justice-appointed trustee,
so when he hawks colloidal
silver male horse vitality pills,
or whatever,
that's going to go to
the corporate entities,
and it stands a good chance
of going to the plaintiffs
before it ever goes to Jones himself.
The plaintiffs in Texas and Connecticut
will be debtors in the bankruptcy estate,
and they'll try to get
as much as they can.
Lawyers are very good at that,
and the court is watching.
So things are bad for Alex Jones,
and they're only going to get worse.
Now, I'm not sure Alex Jones
could even count to 965,
let alone 965 million.
He should really brush up
on his math and STEM skills
with today's sponsor, Brilliant.
Brilliant is an online
learning platform for STEM
that replaces lecture videos
with hands-on, interactive lessons.
Brilliant is for curious learners
both young and old,
professional and inexperienced.
You can quickly learn
to ace your high school
or college math courses,
or just learn stuff that
you always wanted to know.
One of my favorite courses
is all about logic,
something that Jones
obviously never studied.
Brilliant's logic courses
cover liar and truth-teller riddles,
logical fallacies,
machine logic,
and even some strategic game theory.
Logic is a crucial skill
that lawyers need every day,
and Brilliant's statistics
and finance classes
are just as good.
Now, Brilliant lets you learn by doing,
rather than listening to
hours of boring lectures.
Learning through doing is
scientifically proven to be
the most effective way
to master a new skill.
The courses have storytelling,
interactive challenges,
and problems to solve.
Now, you can sign up and
start learning for free today
by clicking on the link
that's on screen right now,
or down in the description.
The first 200 people to sign up
will also get 20% off
their annual subscription.
So by clicking on the
link that's on screen,
or in the description,
you'll get 20% off your
subscription to Brilliant.
Plus, clicking that link
really helps out this channel.
And after that, click on this playlist,
for more LegalEagle,
or I'll see you in court.